Booya Booya everybody we got details on
cyborg coming to Titan season 1 season 2
Doom Patrol and we got confirmation on
Wonder Woman too so if you didn't know
Wonder Woman - is gonna take place
during the 1980s I'll talk about Titans
first just because we have way more of
that stuff there's a bunch of plot
details that dropped online so I'll talk
about which ones I actually think are
legit and then I'll talk about Wonder
Woman - we know a little bit about that
but Geoff Johns and the producers of
started posting stuff so if you're
finding me for the first time be sure to
subscribe to get all the DC videos
there's a new round of the Legion ring
giveaway all you have to do to enter
that is be a subscriber and leave a
comment on the video so the big deal
with cyborg is is that we got a
description for the Doom Patrol series
and they actually put cyborg in the
description for that so people are like
okay clearly he's gonna be a character
inside the Titans universe because Doom
Patrol is debuting during Titan season 1
so it's like literally the same
characters just going off into their own
series and cyborg is gonna be one of the
big headliners so it's like okay clearly
they're eventually working up to cyborg
coming to Titans now we actually have
some more details about that they're
auditioning the cyborg character so a
couple of scenes post it online so I'll
add a little bit of that here but they
drop a couple of f-bombs so it gives you
a good idea for how much more hardcore
titans is going to be than the regular
CW DC TV shows like flash arrow legends
of tomorrow Supergirl Myka Kelly who
plays the dev character has still been
posting stuff for behind the scenes so
it seems like they're still shooting
Titan season 1 even though they were
supposed to be done by now
but there was a rumor that they changed
a little bit from the very end of the
season so they wanted to extend the
amount of shooting time so they could
just clean stuff up and add stuff where
they wanted most of these cyborg
audition scenes seem like they're set up
for Doom Patrol stuff but then just like
Donna Troy who we've seen pop up
throughout a couple different Titans
moments like she's had a couple of
scenes but she's not a big Titan season
1 character she's gonna be a bigger
character during season 2 that also kind
of sounds like what's going on with this
universe of shows so as of right now I'm
just kind of thinking of Titans as being
sort of the arrow of the Titans verse
like the show that propagates all the
other shows like right now they're
auditioning
swampthing character we don't know when
that series is gonna premiere it's
probably gonna be like 2020 before we
see that so I wouldn't be surprised if
he pops up on Titan's season 2 a little
bit but here's a little bit from that
scene just for warned there's a couple
if you're wondering why they're allowed
to drop f-bombs on Titan's but not on
the CW dctp shows is because the CW is
regulated by agencies that tell national
networks what they're allowed to do
during what time of day what kind of
nudity that you can show streaming
services aren't regulated by agencies
the same ways so that's why stuff on big
networks like CW NBC ABC CBS look way
more tame by comparison there are a
couple plot details that have posted
online some of them I think are legit so
I'm just gonna talk about the ones that
I actually think are legit so one is is
that brother blood is not going to be
the main villain of the season he's just
gonna be set up for Trigon but Trigon
also will be a big tease at the end like
Wow
Trigon exists he's as big otherworldly
force setting up the terror of Trigon
arc over the first couple of seasons so
remember how the flash TV show kind of
did a version of flashpoint over the
first three seasons of the show like
first we learned about reverse flash
killing Barry's mother then we actually
get to the real flashpoint moment of it
all at the beginning of season 3 so just
kind of expect the same type of
treatment with Titans in the terror of
Trigon like you learn of the existence
of Trigon through Ravens storyline then
over the course of the first couple of
seasons you start to see other aspects
of that storyline manifest you have the
Church of blood brother blood so they do
say that the main two focuses of season
1 are going to be Robin turning into
Nightwing or sort of leaving
Batman and leaving the Robin name
transitioning tonight wing it Ravens are
developing her powers so like when we
first meet her she's slowly starting to
realize what her powers are like she's a
normal person just having trouble
existing in the real world because of
all the weird stuff that's going on
inside her head you started to see her
powers manifest over the course of the
season remember it's about 13 episodes
so like you slowly see her ramped up her
power level as you learn more about the
church' blood brother blood
Trigon her father and her mother the way
they're describing Beast Boy drank
season one is kind of a Raven style arc
like there aren't parallel arcs they
slowly discover their powers and they
get more powerful as the season goes on
Beast Boy will talk to animals he will
eventually turn green and look like he
does in the comics but he won't have his
full abilities the first time you meet
him he'll slowly bond with Raven they'll
learn about their powers together most
of the descriptions of Jason Todd sound
like what we've been talking about like
have you seen any of the Red Hood videos
that I've done
they have Jason Todd is a character on
the show but he's still alive he hasn't
become Red Hood yet it as you would
expect I think a lot of you predicted
this is that they are intending on
making a Red Hood TV show but they can't
do that till they turn him into Red Hood
so no idea how long that would take and
probably like the first two to three
seasons I don't think they're gonna wait
too long because Red Hood is a really
popular character but their timeline for
Nightwing actually seems pretty fast
like I would have assumed that they
would have waited a couple years to try
and turn him into Nightwing I'm not
gonna hold my breath on that I do know
that he's going to become Nightwing so
it could be at the beginning of season
two it could be way further down the
road moving into Wonder Woman two
territory you probably heard a little
bit about this movie it's supposed to
take place during the 80s Geoff Johns
just posted this picture Wonder Woman 84
so that doesn't tell you exactly what
the plot is going to be other than it's
gonna involve a cold war conflict but it
does let you know it's gonna take place
during 1984 so right now the movie is
scheduled for release November 2019 so a
little less than a year after the
Aquaman movie but there are a couple big
events in real life that happened during
1984 involving the Soviet Union in the
Cold War so I should actually say that
Cheeta was confirmed as a character
Kristen Wiig is going to be playing her
I don't know what she's gonna look like
exactly but obviously it's gonna have to
be motion cat
sure so they can do her cheetah special
effects but when you're thinking about
real-world events for them to base the
plot of this movie on like obviously
there's some big conflict nuclear war
that Wonder Woman probably helps avert
cheetah is probably involved in trying
to precipitate that the really big
events that happened around that time in
real life are the prime minister of
india was assassinated Ronald Reagan was
elected US president at the end of the
year but earlier in the year he joked
about bombing the Soviet Union two world
powers threatening nuclear global
annihilation at the drop of a hat and
there are a lot of people that are
pointing towards the George Orwell 1984
book which I don't know will necessarily
have any involvement in the plot of the
movie but maybe Etha matically let me
know in the comments though is this is
gonna be a Soviet Union cold war
conflict movie what do you think the big
conflict is going to be like the idea
that someone's gonna launch a bunch of
nuclear weapons and destroy the world
that feels like a very Wonder Woman
problem to have to solve but what will
happen is is they just dropped some new
ant-man the wasp footage there was a new
game of Thrones promo that drops all try
to get videos out for that as fast as
possible leave all your requests in the
comments below remember Titans is still
supposed to premiere at the end of the
summer
so we'll keep posting updates on that as
I get more news but we don't have too
much longer before Comic Con happens so
click here for all my other Titans
videos and click here for brand new
flash thank you so much for watching
everybody stay awesome I'll see you guys
tonight